cela aura pris 13 heures 13 heures de
négociations intensives pour en arriver
à une entente de principe entre les
représentants du gouvernement et ceux de
quatre cent mille employés de l'état ces
pourparlers portaient sur les salaires
et sur les retraites je joue à notre
chef de bureau à québec
sebastian ministre a tenu les syndicats
n'ont dévoilé de détails à l'issue de ce
blitz de négociations mais il ya
certains chiffres qui commencent à
circuler
oui ces chiffres que nous avons obtenus
ne sont pas confirmées de source
officielle on les traite donc avec
précaution mais voici les chiffres qui
circulent pour l'année en cours l'année
2015 les syndiqués de l'état votre
recevraient un montant forfaitaire
d'environ 500 $ pour 2016 l'augmentation
serait d'un an et demi pour cent en 2010
est de 1,75 pour cent en 2010 8 2%
d'augmentation et en 2019 le
gouvernement appliquerait un autre
montant forfaitaire d'environ 250 $ si
vous additionnez tous à vous arrivez à
des augmentations de salaire de 5,25
pour cent sur une période de cinq ans
plus les montants forfaitaires
il faut ajouter en plus la relativité
salariale qui est évalué à environ 2 5%
et des aménagements sectorielle qui font
encore monter un peu plus les
augmentations de salaires qui se
situerait donc autour de 8 ou 9 % sur
une période de dix ans pour l'âge de 50
ans
alors pour l'instant est ce qu'on peut
dire qui sort gagnant qui sort perdant
de cette entente
alors pour répondre à cette question il
faut se poser la question quels étaient
les objectifs de chacune des parties
les syndicats voulaient stopper
l'appauvrissement de leurs membres
voulaient faire en sorte qu'on préserve
leur pouvoir d'achat à lever tout neuf
pour cent sur une période de cinq ans on
y est presque alors ce ça pourrait être
acceptable pour les syndicats et les
objectifs du gouvernement c'était de
respecter son cadre financier
là dessus on peut pas objectivement dire
que le cadre financier a été respectée
parce que on n'a pas eu ce cadre
financier n'a pas été rendu public
il faut se fier à la parole de martin
coiteux qui dit que le cadre financier a
été respectée cela dit ce cadre
financier il a évolué au cours de la
négociation parce que le gouvernement a
bonifié son offre salariale
au cours de cette négociation pour en
arriver à cette entente d'aujourd'hui
alors les détails seront présentés aux
instances syndicales demain on verra
comment vont réagir
indiqué merci beaucoup sébastien je vous
en prie au revoir